okay this is for remembering keelon
she's working on all the things all
ideals of the arc no am i as you can
guess doing it from a young side of
things I'm doing it from a hinge side of
things which means my energy print body
mechanics everything my reconciliation
mandate of yin and young I have to do it
all I don't just do whatever you
understand it is therefore as prescribed
as hers this for Kevon wasn't didn't she
was up I could do whatever but she can
do whatever but in ki Lanza her she is
doing an asset ritual it is rule
governed behavior I am also doing that
okay so the rule is that I'm not
grabbing her wrist I am pushing that the
wrist so if you close your fingers you
still want to pushing up the wrist okay
that's not what I mean when I say not
grabbing to me
just grabbing is this and this is not
the energy print for this technique so
I'm going to come in now when I come in
I'm not going to brace on the ground and
fulcrum at the hips don't move I am
coming in with a young orientation so
she doesn't move my center is moving and
I should be able to project
you see that and you're not doing that
like this and definitely not like this
so whether you close your fingers or not
it's irrelevant
your Center is in your hand and as at
this point manifesting itself so she's
not going to move and I'm going to have
a projection drill keep extension
different right yes different Oh
okay let's see we can't we can to bring
their sinner into the tech hi okay so
I'm coming in like that
now I have that intention of coming in
and displace so you see where her spine
is right in in a social violence there
is an innate tendency towards
territoriality that means the person
will seize this space and their
aggression will include a takeover of
that space do you see that you are doing
that in abstract form but when you do
this this is nothing okay so make sure
that your projection is happening from
what I want to call spinal displacement
her spine is there and I'm moving my
spine into that spot you get that fake
so she goes
[Music]
now I'm going to reconcile that energy
okay as you as you watch them she's got
energy there's going to be a pressure
buildup right here do you feel that what
I'm going to do instead is realize
that's happening because I'm resisting
okay so she moves I let it go up not
after then I go not before and not more
that is necessary do you see so just
so there's no contention just let's work
up I get rid of that contention let's
try that
okay so remember we kissed
role is as prescribed so the
prescription was to displace right but
with this attack get it
not with this attack
alright not what this is not with this
attack okay
all of those are as goofy as the last
one because you were asked to do a
certain thing and you didn't do it so
when you come in and I push and you
start to go like that you see that you
can only do that because you stop
pushing so if you look my Energy's gold
necklace do you see that so when she
goes in she just keeps it up and you see
what it does to her
she keeps that intention right over here
when you have that okay who bent you see
that's the counter technically if you
keep on was up or angie was they were
just good in here and then you know what
nobody would do it again okay so just
what's happening is in your psychology
you thought I said knock them down and
then you forgot you had a prescribed way
of doing spinal displacement okay so I
go in with that my arms stays here
I don't do that got it okay so now I
have all the other rules that apply
after this first part so my body goes in
and this same thing I have to maintain
organization so as she starts as I feel
that Sookie that I just fell in I don't
pull out a technique nor do i and she
starts to go disconnect my Center from
my grid
she's tasked with all of that and I'm
tasked with all of that so you can see
I'm here there is a relationship between
my head and foot which means I
Center when I break that relationship I
don't have Center so I'm over here she
goes and I fall in the same way okay
I'm harmonizing her young energy the way
I'm receiving it but through an engage
Center she continues so my Center is
being utilized to hold the organization
just like hers
so just as I'm coming in this is
disconnected Center so too at the end
watch the end
watch me maintain my Center what so I'm
exercising this organization okay let's
go okay so I'm harmonizing get young
energy with the organizing and utilize
Center okay I have my prescribed initial
energy print so I go body moves in now
this is what I mean it's organized so
she doesn't just move my arm go you see
I keep my Center in in my arm she is
going to do a young move do you see
and I'm yielding to it on my body so she
does y'all boo I'm not going like that
go I'm not racing here so right I'm
learning how when someone pushes on me
by yielding just because natural to my
beam okay you player shot me out of the
deal so the same thing goes for the MA
you come in here ups a clash but the
earth here is going to be young to me so
as she pushes me in you see how I'm
blending with the mat surface okay now
here's that last part
don't disconnect organize your Center
so you get that exercise too okay so in
I go you'll yield to the mat organized
hey let's go